les filets femmes alors que les hommes
ne sont pas pressés d'égalité
[Musique]
et ce mouvement là parce que je
comprends pas pourquoi il ya beaucoup
plus de restrictions des vêtements au
niveau des chiffres et pour juste en
cours on peut se promener à bord contenu
sur twitter ça tourne petit emploi ont à
dire et je m'y attendais pas forcément
j'ai surtout des compliments
après il ya toujours des gens préfèrent
les deux pays sinon tu coules engagée
s'est violemment
[Musique]
un accroc octobre sans soutien gorge et
un pantalon vous les hanches sont
dévoilés parce qu'il y avait tout donc
ça dure
[Musique]
tenu que je rêvais revue stoppé 14 parce
que je pense je voudrais être libre de
porter ce qu'on veut quand on veut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour moi leur campus même ya des chiques
même ce qui m'intéressait faisait là
c'est l'offre que le mou en profite on
se souvient même pas
[Musique]
je me demande comment tu le perds
bancaire d'être en face il ya tellement
de moments c'était de violences peut on
est carrément mesurer cette initiative
de casser les codes vestimentaires c'est
génial et ses compères possible
[Musique]
jusque les lycées il nous laisse nous
habiller comme le veut arranger beaucoup
je sais que dans certains lycées c'est
possible mais pas maintenant
non quand même a des côtés il aimerait
vite passé et sans encombre gamal sont
comme vu le temps pour se mettre deux
mois devraient tous les fils et femmes
alors que les hommes ne sont pas créés
ainsi l'égalité et éduquer les élèves
bas entre des plus jeune âge à ne pas la
sexualité autant jeu ce qui ne devrait
pas l'être et je pense que ça se doit
commencer même avant jc
[Musique]